all right y'all we are back and we
always love to shine a light on Broadway
shows making their Mark here in the city
these days Kimberly a Kimbo has been the
Talk of the Town earning five tonies
last year the most of any show including
best musical the show follows a teenager
with a condition that causes her body to
age faster than it should so she goes
through all those trials and
tribulations of adolescence looking like
a 72-year-old woman and that's just the
starting point now performing though the
hopeful act one fin Al this time give it
up for the cast of Kimberly
[Applause]
aimo time I put aside the
doubt this
[Music]
time this
time oh this time maybe things work out
[Music]
out this
time oh this time
time oh this
time found
a it's night in
County
everywhere and we finally got
invited
time
[Music]
everywhere this time
everybody this
time time hit the road this time stay on
track time my voice won't
crack
time
[Music]
[Applause]
PR not like the other
[Music]
time oh time no one a
make a
[Music]
wish
once more let's here for the cast of
Kimberly or Kimbo everybody Kimberly
Kimbo is launching a national tour this
fall and you can also catch us here in
New York on Broadway through April 28th
get your tickets online people we'll be
right back with what I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
liking thank you guys yall have a great
night I'm going
home